[Musique]
extrait de la vidéo présentée ce matin
la journée des investisseurs de
bombardier avec vous ce soir éric martel
pdg de bombardier bonsoir oui bonsoir
vous dirigez aujourd'hui monsieur martel
une entreprise de environ 13000 employés
qui a déjà eu quand même les 50 60 mille
employés dans le passé est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la restructuration de
bombardier est terminée et pts et oui on
est heureux de l'annoncer c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on avait une journée avec
nos investisseurs pour expliquer le plan
match sur les cinq prochaines années
alors on a présenté notre plan qui
ciblent purement l'aviation des affaires
un marché qu'on connaît bien dans lequel
on a bien fait aussi pendant plusieurs
années alors c'était seul objectif de
notre journée aujourd'hui de faire cette
tradition là
et d'annoncer notre plan de 5 alors dans
les prochaines années ce qu'on anticipe
évidemment c'est un marché évidemment
menu la pandémie ans qu'ils nous ont
obligés à ajuster nos cadences de
production on voit une reprise lente par
contre ce qui est intéressant
présentement c'est qu'on voit une
reprise extrêmement dynamique des achats
de nos ventes
alors ça ça nous permet de regarnir
notre notre carnet de commandes et ça ça
nous donne un peu une vue sur les
prochaines années alors on a un plan
qu'on a présenté aujourd'hui que je
dirais conservateur parce qu'on n'a pas
misé sur des augmentations de cadence
très très grande mais plutôt tranquille
ici 2025 et vous misez donc beaucoup sur
la maintenance sur le service après
vente
vous avez parlé beaucoup de réduction de
la dette aujourd'hui des intérêts avec
la vente de bombardier transport vous
parlez aussi de réduction des coûts
prévus de 400 millions de dollars
refinancement aussi d'une partie de
votre dette
je vous posais la question sur la
restructuration parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on est encore chez
bombardier en train de préparer le bilan
financier pour être capable
éventuellement peut-être d'être
véritablement en croissance la réalité
c'est que notre marché et est en train
de montrer des signes de croissance
alors le marché dans lequel on 9
c'est la bonne nouvelle est très
dynamique présentement
et on a reçu comme vous le savez de la
vente des actifs qu'on a fait l'an
dernier où à la fin au début de cette
année des sommes importantes qui vont
servir à payer des dettes qui était
beaucoup trop et c'était ça le problème
de bombardier depuis quelques années
c'est qu'on avait une dette qui était
beaucoup trop lourde pour l'entreprise
alors on a dévoilé aujourd'hui notre
approche comment on fait pour améliorer
la situation
est ce qu'on cible en 2025 c'est d'avoir
une profitabilité d'environ 1.5
milliards de dollars sur ce qu'on
appelle l'ebitda et un ratio de dette
nette avait environ 2 3 ce qui est
parfait pour nous ce qui serait une
bonne situation alors on a un plan
concret pour se rendre dans les
prochaines années
mais le plan commence rapidement parce
qu'on voit rembourser beaucoup de
blagues vous êtes le seul manufacturier
à fabriquer des avions d'affaires qui
fabrique des avions d'affaires si on
vous compare par exemple beaucoup avec
gulf stream qui était quand même un
groupe qui tire des revenus du secteur
de la défense le groupe propriétaire si
un ralentissement dans les avions
d'affaires est ce que vos concurrents
puisqu'ils sont aussi dans la défense ne
sont ils pas mieux positionné que vous
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on a
annoncé qu'on voulait croître de façon
importante notre après service alors
c'est un business qui l'an passé c'est
environ 1 milliard de revenus en 2010
9,5 et 1.2 donc avant la pandémie on
veut croître ce d'environ un milliard
dans les prochaines années ce qui est
très possible et ça ça va donner une
résilience beaucoup plus grande à
bombardier parce que c'est un business
qui est stable habituellement même si
une crise économique ou d'autres
facteurs
ce business la va passer au travers
alors ça va donner de la résilience que
bombardier ça va représenter d'ici cinq
ans 27 % de nos revenus aujourd'hui 6,8
alors et c'est un business qui ne
demande pas beaucoup de liquidités est
une business qui génère des liquidités
pour l'entreprise et c'est ce qu'on a
besoin justement pour être capable
d'absorber des soubresauts de l'économie
pourrait avoir
françois legault a dit le 11 février que
le gouvernement du québec est prêt à
aider bombardier mais avec des garanties
si c'est nécessaire bien sûr est ce
qu'une négociation en cours en ce moment
avec le gouvernement du québec
y a pas de négociations en cours avec le
gouvernement bombardier est à les
emprunter sur les marchés de l'argent
privé l'an dernier pour réussir à passer
au travers
la pandémie ici on a même rembourser ce
prêt l'on avait d'aujourd'hui qu'on
avait besoin d'un être temporaire on a
remboursé ce prélat en février dernier à
quelques semaines et on se prépare à
redéployer aussi le capital du résultat
des ventes pour baisser notre niveau de
pertes et nous rendre beaucoup plus
agile les objectifs du passé pour 2020
n'ont pas vraiment été atteint a fallu
des membres est pratiquement
l'entreprise pour éviter la faillite ou
la chute
en quoi votre stratégie aujourd'hui pour
2025 est aujourd'hui la bonne on est une
compagnie complètement différente de ce
qu'on a été aujourd'hui les avions
d'affaires ont toujours été une division
qui performait bien chez chez bombardier
depuis plusieurs années et aujourd'hui
on se sent ancrée j'ai une équipe de
direction extrêmement compétentes par
rapport à ce marché là moi même j'en
avais été à la direction il ya quelques
années
alors tout ça ensemble on comprend bien
le marché qu'on a devant nous on a un
excellent portefeuille de produits aussi
il faut savoir que le global ses 1500
qu'on fabrique au québec on doit on est
extrêmement fiable parce que c'est c'est
le bateau admiral de l'industrie à nos
clients ce matin 10 est le roi
incontesté de tous les avions d'affaires
pour ses performances sa qualité alors
et sa fiabilité aussi déjà même si on a
seulement 50 appareils en service
alors on est très fier de ça son
faisceau au québec dans nos usines et si
fabriqués à montréal on fabrique
complètement les challengers et la
finition intérieure de nos avions
globaux et on pense qu'avec le portfolio
de produits qu'on a on est en excellente
mesure les investissements sont derrière
nous on doit capitaliser sur ses
investissements dans les cinq prochaines
années et c'est ce qu'on entend faire
pour aller capturer une plus grande part
de marché
un mot en terminant monsieur martel est
ce que vous êtes à l'aise avec
l'arrangement de départ de 17 millions
de dollars pour l'ancien pdg alain
bellemare à qui vous avez succédé
et que je ferai pas de commentaire
monsieur fillion sur cet arrangement là
je n'étais pas là c'est une histoire du
passé alors je ne ferai pas de
commentaire sur son avez-vous vous ce
type d'arrangement advenant votre départ
j'ai des arrangements qui sont
différents qui sont d'ailleurs
disponibles dans notre circulaire qu'on
ait circulé l'an dernier convoi
circulait encore dans quelques semaines
confirmant son la grande transparence
d'accord on va les lire certainement
merci beaucoup merci merci beaucoup au
revoir au revoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne i
cirdi